hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round 8 of the
2013 candidates tournament this time
it's a game between two time control
junkies alexandra district versus a
vasilyev on Chuck now a Viswanathan
Anand once said that Greece Chuck
probably goes into time trouble and
purpose because he can think more
clearly under pressure but as far as
vastly one shoe goes no one can really
tell why why this is happening to him so
far in the previous seven rounds he was
in time trouble every single game and he
already lost two of the games on time so
let's see what what this game brings to
us and you will see by the time we reach
the end of the 2013 candidates
tournament I will be very happy you've
seen all of these games but played by
vastly one Chuck but to understand why
you will have to see all of the games so
let's see it and we don't have a couple
of hours before we actually start with
the game here is lastly why don't you
just you know relaxing before the game
starts also a nice photo of of Alexander
very shook before the game and here is a
game after a couple of opening moves
there you can see nothing nothing weird
about the photo you know just just do
very strong players playing chess so in
the first for the first move Alexander
Greece shook decided to play efore and I
don't think vastly lunch was very happy
to see II for why I don't think I was
the one she was very happy because we
actually have a photo of this moment
here you can see Richard played efore
and Evandro is definitely not happy
about this who knows why why this is so
he might he might have prepared
something like 4 d 4 or maybe Knight to
f3 and he maybe spent a couple of hours
for openings and then he sees he 4 on
the board and of course who would be
happy but ok he opens with c5 the
Sicilian defense we have Knight to f3
knight c6 and the d4c captures Knight
captures Knight to f6 all pretty
standard in 93 and here we have g6
it's been a long time since we had the
DX
the dragon variation Bishop to e3 Bishop
to g7 and now Bishop to c4 we have Queen
to a5 castles castles and the Bishop
back to b3 b6 and Knight to d5 so this
is all pretty standard here it seems
like white is offering black this very
nice efore pawn but of course you know
nothing in chests nothing is free if you
grab this then white will simply
eliminate the defender of the 7 pawn
after you captured them Knight captures
with Czech have to remove the King White
has a lot of a lot of good options here
at the CSEC c6 pawn is hanging the d6
pawn will will be hanging after you kick
away the night so not nothing really
nice for black here so after Knight to
d5 rook to e8 eventually defense the
pawn and prepares to push it Knight
captures on f6 Bishop captures and c3
now we have Knight to e5 and h3 now you
don't want to play something like f4
immediately then you allow Knight g4
this attacks your dark square Bishop
there's really no good place where you
can move the dark square Bishop so
basically you'd be giving up the bishop
repair if you did this so first h3 if f4
is ever played then the g4 square is no
longer available for the night
and Queen to a6 I'm what a more active
square for the Queen than a 5 and from
from a6 the queen is now guarding both
c4 and d3 if this night ever decides to
jump anywhere their night the c2 we have
night 2 D 3 and now Queen to f3
microscope notice how the bishop on b3
and the Queen and f3 are eyeing that f7
point if this special paper moves it
will be it will be very unpleasant for
black
such would be the case if you played
something like like Knight captures on
b2 if you did something like this you
know maybe we want to grab pawn then you
get nice to be for now the night gets an
extra move because you play night before
by attacking the Queen on a6 and after
the Queen moves and now comes Knight to
d5 threatening at Knight captures on f6
and after you move the bishop now you
can move the bishop because the knight
is blocking the bishop on b3 but here
comes at night to b6
you open up a discovery now the post
Queen and the bishop are attacking f7
and also the knight is attacking the
rook
so after Bishop to e6 Bishop captures
pawn captures now you grab the rook and
you are up the exchange rook captures
and for the price of this one pawn you
just lost the exchange so definitely you
don't want to capture this so glistrup
immediately goes to Bishop to e6 he
counters the bishop on b3 we have Bishop
to d4 Bishop captures Knight captures
and now Bishop to c4 you could also
capture unbe 3 after a capture some b3
it's not like although the queen is
attacked there's nowhere for you to play
the Queen it seems like you're losing
the night on d3 but I can actually play
Knight to d5 and after white moves the
Queen and black and simply move his his
Queen and all is well and a similar idea
happened in the game but first the
Bishop to c4 by von Schuch rook F to be
won and now Knight to e5 Queen to e3 and
now Bishop captures pawn captures and
now Queen to b6 so like we said a
similar idea rook to a3 defending the be
3 points of the night is now able to
move a 6 and now rook to d1 look at the
c8 we have nice to see to an algorithm
offers a trade of Queens Queen captures
an e3 and Knight captures an e3 and
Knight to d7 know already this is a move
24 event is already in in serious time
trouble now we have f3 King to f8 and
King to f2 rock to c6 event is now
preparing to double up rooks on the C
file g 4e 6 h4 and king to e7 rope to a5
rook e to see it now we want to doubles
on the C file
King to g3 and now h6 rope to d2 night
to c5 and rook back to a3 an algorithm
is forced to guard the b3 pawn with his
rook a5 now if of course if rook
captures the knight we'll be able to
capture on B 3 and this will win the
exchange so tonight's the C - we have
rook to a6 and rook to d1 rook c2 a8 now
event two doubles
transfers his doubled rooks from the C
file to the a file and he wants to push
a four we have Knight to d4 the idea is
nice to be five because now that a5 has
been pushed and now the b v square is
available for the white knight and after
the night comes here then the d6 pawn
will be very weak so King to d7 Knight
it does come to b5 and now we have a
five this is moved 36 and at it was a I
believe it was at this point and this is
the idea of the title of this video here
if I took before he pressed the clock he
knocked down a couple of griffix pawns
and it's against the rules to hit the
clock before before all of the pawns and
all the pieces are where they are
supposed to be so it was at this point
if one chick had 5 seconds on the clock
and he had to make three more moves and
instead of hitting the clock you know
which would be which wouldn't be
according to rules you know but everyone
else would do it I mean you have 5
seconds on the clock you want to hit the
clock and Daniel fix like the pawns and
the pieces but even took instead of
hitting the clock he fixed all the
points where they belong all the grease
chip spawns where they belong and only
then did he hit the clock but then he
did not have enough time to reach time
control but okay before he managed to
play a capture some v4c capture some
before was played and now night nights
to e6 here not a night capture Sun b6
was played by Chris Cook this is moved
39 and it was in this position that
vastly when she lost the game
once again in this candidates tournament
on time but you know even if he didn't
he just was lost upon here there's
really nothing for you to do of course
if you capture here then that's really
not good rook captures captures and then
Brooke captures an a8 you would be down
the exchange what you have to do after
this Knight captures and these six you
have to capture on a three and after
captures move the King so there are no
discoveries but yeah you would have to
defend this position being upon down but
yeah it's interesting
this is the third game in this
candidates tournament vastly once you've
lost on time and it's a very interesting
I mean if if he didn't proceed the way
he did if there wasn't correct play on
his part he would definitely manage to
get a move 40 and the game would go on
but it's interesting what do you think
how would you what would you do in this
situation if you had five seconds on the
clock you had to make three moves to
reach time control and you knocked over
a couple of your opponent's bones would
you hit the clock and then fix the
points or would you fix the pawns well
your time on the clock is ticking and
you're losing precious seconds so yeah
that's that's the kind of the player
vastly von Schuch is and it's very
interesting
before you had like two and a half hours
to reach time control now I mean in the
in these days entered today I have only
one and a half hour to reach time
control and one other important thing
there is no increment for the first 40
moves so here the rules were you have an
hour and a half for the first 40 moves
then you have another hour for the next
20 moves and only after moves 60 is
their time increase their you know time
increment after every move so a lot of
other tournaments did have time
increment in those days and the
candidates tournament did not have it so
maybe a bunch wasn't used this but you
know either way this is the third game
in this tournament he lost on time so
far so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it if I took definitely
didn't but you know such such is the way
of chess and you will see that when we
reach the end of this 2013 candidates
tournament that you will be very glad
you saw all of this games by vasily von
Schuch so yeah i would like to thank all
of our total and david Hohenstein
corinthian i have for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
with two more games from round 8 of the
2013 candidates tournament thank you all
and I will see you soon